it's changed all of us
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my umbrella academy
season 2 video explaining the ending
with that big teaser for season three
was going to be
yes they've been renewed for season
three so they will be doing more
episodes
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
and even though it should go without
saying as the title of the video implies
careful for spoilers from all of
umbrella academy season two so we'll be
explaining everything that happens
all the big secrets that they reveal and
what's going on with season three
i'll just number these as we go along to
stay organized there were a bunch of
easter eggs and a bunch of comic book
references that they get into even
though they changed
a lot about the comic book plot from
umbrella academy
love the big shout out for watchmen
during this too the end is nigh
but as you all saw the umbrella academy
is finally able to reunite and meet with
their father reginald hargreaves in the
past but he can't stand them
just like it kind of seems like he
couldn't stand them when he was trying
to raise them like he just has this deep
dislike of children why would i ever
adopt
seven children if i hate children but he
does wind up talking to five and a lot
of other people in earlier episodes
about
the uncertainty of time travel and how
everything can change in a matter of
seconds and how even if you think you're
doing everything right
and you know the future even changing
minor things in the past can have vast
consequences in the future
so obviously this is all set up for that
big twist at the end
as well as that new time travel
superpower that five develops in the
finale
it's also important to note when you
think about them messing with the past
obviously there's a lot of things that
they mess with even though it seems like
they're able to fix things by the end
they still make a lot of really big
changes
like diego for instance did everything
he could to mess with mother in the past
resulting in her turning against
reginald hargreaves they also joke about
him letting pogo loose you let my chimp
loose
more on that in the new future timeline
that they create in a second
so even though it seems like they fixed
everything in the end they did not fix
everything they eventually learned that
it's vanya again who caused the
apocalypse because as
diego says vanya is always going to be
the bomb but the whole reason she causes
it this time
is because she's being tortured into
psychosis by the fbi who thinks that
she's a russian
through that whole subplot with the wife
harlan and her husband
she breaks loses control of her powers
again and causes this big explosion the
reason why it causes the apocalypse or
leads to the apocalypse
is because the fbi building where the
blast goes off is so close to jfk's
procession in dallas that the fbi the
government and kennedy
blame it on a russian soviet plot
because it's the cold war so kennedy
declares war on russia
there's a big invasion then full-scale
nuclear war
leading to the apocalypse that we saw in
episode one
they are able to stop her ben sacrifices
himself to say vanya then passes on to
heaven as he implies
the great white light is what he calls
it like a voice is telling me to move on
in a flashback you actually learned that
a younger version of klaus
during his funeral convinced ghost ben
to ignore the voice of god or
whatever you want to call it and just
stays a ghost on planet earth hanging
out with him
and now in this moment in the future
technically their future even though
we're in the past
he's finally moving on like he should
have done years ago so he's like don't
be sad for me i should have done this a
long time ago
the team then realizes that vanya
accidentally passed some of her power to
harlan
when she saved him earlier in the season
he's not able to control it and is
just going off the chain that's what the
red lights and the special energy are
when she's giving him mouth
to mouth trying to revive him they kind
of explained this during season one so
remember that special red energy that
you see
reginald release on his home planet
those lights as they sort of escape in
the flashbacks when his original wife
lay dying and the others of his kind
seem like they're fleeing their planet
in the rockets that is the special
energy that gave
all the children around the world powers
and caused them to be born under those
weird circumstances
at the same time so the showrunner
explained that this is vanya just
sharing some of that special power with
harlan so that's why even when she takes
back most of her power in the finale
from him
harlan is still left with some special
abilities like you see him levitating
that bird as they're driving away
the bird is also clever foreshadowing
for the sparrow academy twists at the
end
they also finally explain who and what
lila
really is during that big final battle
she's secretly
one of their sisters she was one of the
many special children born all over the
world on the same day
with special abilities her ability is
just defined as power
mimicry she can copy the powers of
anyone she encounters even at great
distance as it's shown during her battle
with vanya when she's standing really
far away but she's still able to copy
vanya's powers
they reveal that the handler wanted to
control her as an asset
and plant her as a mole inside the
umbrella academy so she had number five
take out her parents once they kill the
handler lila then
freaks out takes one of the briefcases
and just time travels away to who knows
where until season three
it seems like she still cares about
diego on some level and the family
as well as diego tried to accept her as
one of their own like you're one of us
you're part of the family you just never
knew it make all the game of thrones
sister loving jokes that you want
because now luther is also not the
biggest sister lover inside the group
so she'll probably help them with a much
bigger threat in season 3 even though
they're implying that the sparrow
academy is this bigger threat
there's probably something even bigger
that they all have to come together to
stop
that probably gets into some of the
hotel oblivion stuff from the comics so
i'll explain that in a second too
but then the team thinks that they're
returning to 2019 a couple days
after the original apocalypse and
everything is fine but
reginald hargreaves is alive now in 2019
and instead of number five's picture
above the fireplace it's
ben's and it's revealed that he never
wound up creating the umbrella academy
instead he created something called the
sparrow academy
in a very much alive version of ben
shows up followed by five other shadowy
teenagers
in a floating green box that seems like
it's sentient
it just implies that reginald founded a
very different version of the team
in this version of the timeline and some
of the things that they changed in the
past the things that they messed with
caused these big butterfly effect
changes
they're just left to wonder if these are
their enemies or wtf is gonna happen now
what new catastrophe have they
inadvertently caused because as we
learned from the last two seasons
they're usually the ones that wind up
causing the apocalypse that they're
trying to solve usually they find out
about a disaster but then in trying to
stop
it it becomes this big self-fulfilling
prophecy this is also where we get to
the hotel oblivion story line from the
comics
in the comics the hotel oblivion is a
special prison where reginald hargreaves
who we learn as an alien
uses to house all the super villains and
worst beings of the universe that they
catch
during season two the show keeps
referring to reginald's quote-unquote
interests
in the dark side of the moon so it's
likely that that's where the tv version
of hotel oblivion is located
in the comic book story line this
alternate version of an umbrella academy
team
shows up at the end of the hotel
oblivion story line
meeting the main team and they have a
similar reaction like who are you
where did you come from are you friend
or foe what's going on here why is there
an alternate version of the umbrella
academy
running around so if you look at the
outlines of these alternate team members
it seems like there's still
two girls and four boys just like the
original team
i'm assuming that the green box is like
the alternate version of pogo on the
team because there's no pogo anywhere to
be found here in his pictures and above
the fireplace
so in this new timeline think about how
mother broke it off with reginald in the
past after she learned some of his
darker secrets like i can't be a part of
this i can't be with you
peace i'm out of here through the
flashbacks and pogo's origin story you
learn that he was always more loyal to
mother so i'm assuming that in the new
timeline
reginald never got back together with
her and reconciled and she just went off
to do her own thing
pogo going with her so mother might also
be
alive in present day 2019 as well so the
big tease of season three is also that
all these characters who have died
are now alive but they're alternate
versions also remember
since they went so far to tease harlan's
powers at the end of the finale
an older adult version of harlan might
come back to and have something to do
with causing a new apocalypse or helping
them prevent it
and as for why it's called the sparrow
academy and not the umbrella academy
earlier in the season when they were
thumbing through all of his files
in his office you look at his desk there
there's actually a symbol of a sparrow
on one of the files that's probably the
inspiration for creating the
quote-unquote
sparrow academy and i think in the new
timeline all these kids are different
because reginald hargreaves released
that special energy into the world
later in the timeline than normal so all
the kids around the world weren't born
till later in the timeline
that explains why ben and all the other
characters are dressed looking like
they're kind of teenagers
and because in the past when he met them
he felt like the og
team was such a bunch of screw-ups that
he decided to swerve on them in the
future and adopt kids that he felt could
become
superior to the og team the only real
funny thing that i haven't addressed in
the video yet though is that twist
ending with the swede the one that's
left alive he winds up joining klaus's
cult
destiny's children obviously that's
meant to be a big joke about destiny's
child the group
and him reciting the lyrics don't go
chasing waterfalls like it was a
scripture
the way it seems like they're playing
this time travel twist is more of an
avengers endgame style twist where even
if you change the past you can't really
affect your future you just create
alternate new realities and they're just
living in this new alternate reality
where things are a little bit different
in the future with a different version
of the team but everyone let me know in
the comments if there's any big
questions you have or anything you felt
like i didn't address
during this video i tried to hit all the
big stuff obviously the big wtf moments
they didn't say when season 3 is
supposed to be released but i'm assuming
they're going to start filming that
sometime
by at least early next year in other
related netflix
things they're working on stranger
things season 4 again right now so we'll
probably get a new stranger things
season 4 trailer sometime
early next year they'll probably release
that sometime towards the end of next
year
but everyone click here for my brand new
stranger things season 4
trailer video and click here for my
brand new benedict cumberbatch doctor
strange 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys
[Music]
tonight